okay so I'm going to start with playing
logos are let's see how this goes should
be a good start good d4 d5
[Music]
a little bit slow here first guys just
trying to make sure that everything is
correct all right so so far that's a
swab piece before and not the best move
only trying to put in a p7 guys trying
to play some kind of Moran normally does
the night already developed you normally
don't push your pawns quite like this
this is probably dubious for some reason
I'm not quite sure why but I don't feel
like wasting time trying to be precise
when this is blitz after all okay but
should be 7/3
before for I'm slow for some reason my
lagging you I'm lagging closeout was all
my windows
okay
all right keep playing normal just three
normally here you could take the pawn it
I've try to put on traditional stuff on
all kind of boring
um suity duster v8 now the whole point
here behind 93 is I want to play e-force
we can't play e5 but then I have Knight
f5 and you fall right into it now in I
have five and now I'm probably gonna win
the game in like two moves maybe it's
not maybe not quite so simple is winning
but it's not in every two moves I'll
probably take on d4 probably take with
the King here um okay probably should've
taken with the night now I get into the
square on c5 got some problems here now
on a queen side but it's still something
ID six just take I don't really want to
take a SUP and give them c5 but it's
it's all winning it's just a question of
style
more than anything it's e5 61
alright so let's see what's going to do
here what is he going to do here that's
here on the solution I mean all those
pieces are kind of not ideally placed
mind you if you can get a king to d6 or
something he's probably doing fine I'm
just I want to play something
traditionally bad because I don't expect
in play g5 maybe he will play g5 and
then I'm not going to be so happy as
myself of course you did it so it's this
is much better for white q4 probably
what the best is now I suppose in fish
appear on a story I don't have any
squares but I'm going to try and come
down here on the H file open up the H
file exchange on come down work h1 or
page six do something like that trying
do something creative on their work h1
maybe hopefully see eyes but probably
it's do something like Kingston 7 this
is all pretty bad though also spawns are
not perfectly placed here they're all a
little bit loose even even though
nothing's no threats okay stay pond not
just a matter of technique anything
should be winning here on primarily
she's black is too many weak black down
an exchange then also black I just an
extra coupon hearing is set up the board
well I did it with the slot c5 I kind of
wasn't not showing a batch technique so
far fortunately decisions completely
winning foot is going to matter
um but still not what ideal alright
except I see for that kind of wasn't
should be a little bit careful here
strangely yeah but II five should be
enough to win fish about three king of
three although he does a Bishop c8 which
I completely missed look how I turn this
replete Lee winning into some kind of
technical and keep on to show actual
technique not quite what I was hoping
for
um okay and yeah now I should see what
technical win
- is right D - keenie to work b-17
Keaney one shouldn't be winning now King
up three might have actually been better
but you're coming upon and this should
be winning
okay now I'm not the one this woman okay
it should be window just see what he's
going to do now a show real technique
that was not very smooth at all mom that
was really not smooth okay all right
let's see so who's up next
that was pretty terrible well play oh
how about this okay
can we do it can we do it or not can we
do it we'll see actually what is that
flag Vatican City it is okay another
swab guide to two games two slogs
surprising I want to show some actual
techniques this game I think I do
okay so I'll play an exchange I'll do is
what is plan is G for so far so theory
there's a so far so theory this VI so
far this is theory I'm going to try and
speak for proper English sorry about
that everyone is making sure we think
everything's good alright looks sitting
okay this is kind of weird this doesn't
look like kind of you know if this will
someone else I probably won't do this
but it's too apt it's too too outside
looks too nice I have to snap there's
nothing else to do
that's probably actually winning once
you take the knight I think maybe could
have played Bishop b4 we next five queen
of five Knight c3 probably it just just
bad but I'm assuming that URI doesn't
realize I'm bishop before I can just
play Queen before I probably should play
Queen d7 or Queen b6
I think work suwon looks pretty good
maybe you can defend work see a queen a
Trixie aquino 14 b7 and now for the coup
d'etat where is it
I do not see it I'm probably going to
play King e2 and some kind of rook c6
idea was rook c1 I mean Bishop d6 is
what he should play on and somehow this
is not like easily winning which is
really kind of annoying
in fact but he doesn't have any moves
here if I think about it so here I could
take and chuck and play with these five
always a possibility it looks pretty
good actually I'm seeing a reason not to
go for this candy 7 or XP 5 will be the
next 2 moves and probably it's going to
be like something like king b7 or c5
work c7 c1 or c8 and then I better find
something or else I'm going to lose I
don't know if that's good or not but on
the flip side yes you use a lot of time
here and maybe figure it out but let's
see okay oh we like these for the Queen
eight for hopefully okay what am i good
Queen b3 clearly theater try and trick
them so I can take the knight here next
move not a guarantee I mean probably
care if he should move something like
move is Queen to a7 maybe I don't know
if that actually works but it seems like
a reasonable try hoping to stop but
Queenie 11 maybe then also ae4 d4 d5
always there maybe not fast probably
clean and seven I should just take
Ritchie sitzen Queen B 5 queenie 8 and
then figure something out
again this is not so simple strangely I
mean this is kind of annoying I'm going
to take a shot here that he'll play 98
allowing e4 and sure enough he does
there we go became some
gaudí five and he doesn't take mine
actually sure what he can do
96 now I think I can just take and if he
takes I take and then the night on d6 is
still 10
um what is the counter I've got what
three pawns three pawns or something for
my one piece that I'm missing probably
hopefully Queen b6 I would assume got
three pawns double pawn so he's still
tied up here so I can probably just
start rolling these beep-beep on an iPod
something like that I'm not so sure but
it seems like it's good it's good an
idea is ending in this position so he
does not so does not have a threat okay
let's just protect this Bishop here they
can't move the King or I'll lose the
night here doc he's kind of my kind of
might even be in just like in signal on
here or you can't move any pieces at all
Musa King he hangs this night he can't
move this Knight you can't move this
Queen because the knight Hank's a camel
is rooks and maybe you start pushing
pawns or something but this looks pretty
ugly now I don't have to do anything I
could also just play a 5 or B 4 but I'd
rather wait just make him on you have to
do something here because I don't think
he can actually I think he's kind of in
Doug's long completely now I'm just
gonna I'll make him go back to b7 and
I'll play a very subtle move like king
q2 and yeah he's kind of actually now
I'm going to be cheeky I'm gonna play a
6 so you can't move this clean anymore
now I kind of have to move some pawns
over here or something okay finally he
caved but unfortunately it's a little
bit too late here as he's going to lose
a bunch of pieces all right so check all
the King g8 or Ricky 7 pretty much
anything wins here but all I could have
played Bishop B so I'm already been a
little bit nicer but it's probably just
too little too late
let's see so no scheme should be up soon
let's see how am I going to play now
alright let's see um
[Music]
once I everyone I'm just going to reload
the screen very quick those little
things like your second
one second if it's going to actually
reload just one second you guys edit
little pop-up stuck on the screen so I
just want to get rid of it and while I
wait while I wait I can't get back in
you guys Oh going on here
um okay this is strange why is it not
reloading
come on so let's go
okay
right back on siding you guys
all right good amber back okay you guys
let's see okay so now that we're back
let's see who took play next um I told
myself that the stars at least at the
very beginning I'm just going to play a
bunch of a bunch of random guys would
rather stay away from playing the guys
like dannion he seems to want to play
mean he always seems to want to play me
so he can lose badly um I'll give him
that chance later on now isn't it's time
though okay so actually I'm trying to
figure out why did I decide to play a
Berlin against somebody who when I'm
supposed to be having a good time here
and not taking this too seriously that
was kind of stupid anyway anyway since
it turned out to be something of a real
line it would help they'll probably put
a Bungie five or III maybe see
three probably one of those three moves
would make the most sense sure enough he
does I'll play six for some to move his
bishop okay it's some kind of Spanish or
something maybe I understand it's gonna
be close to like a Google piano cos
bishops normally the white bishop was a
c4 b3 c2 here it went to be five eight
four c2 probably he still has the option
to go to b3 next move he wants to and
I'll actually make them decide right
away probably going to c2 is better just
to keep open the square on b3 for his
knight from d2 I'm listening and both
passive avoid any tempos on my Bishop
which would be six on so let's see I
wonder what he'll do now you can play
for work e1 probably those are the two
buttons here if that's what I would
expect maybe something like Queen e2
also although the Queen on e2 can get in
the way because it's going to be hard to
play d4 and if you take there always are
threats Knight takes Knight f4 hopefully
h6 I really want to go Bishop e6 but
he'll have Knight g5 so I'll just take
this precaution first for a good move
I'll get the rook out of this line from
this sort of probably it'll take so I'll
just make a pre move no harm if you
take the cream got cancelled if he does
take I save time King each one not the
strange mode definitely not to evoke
expecting but I'll continue stick stick
so plans makes more sense on inventing
problems here at night eh - I'm not
really sure what he's trying to call
China if you want to go to 94 put the
other night ask three maybe play out for
maybe however that's a little bit a
little bit dubious in this position but
also keep playing normal is Queen d7
maybe sac on h3 at some point maybe
depending how he sets up of course it is
inflate GG for now it's time to punish
him please cheer for so you can't really
push age 40 G for saying up for is going
to be opening it up too much so
hopefully be for cuz I figure here and
he hasn't opened the a files now if we
keep this a file close his rooks not
going anywhere
I'm obviously everything I say seems to
be wrong because I said he would she
before he can't play it for up for its
to loosening is going to make me have to
prove it
hopefully he's not listening maybe is of
course I have to take civil rights will
go out five on here their money moves
I'll just take on c3 to open up the B
file from our rook just in case I needed
I don't probably don't need to take but
it makes more sense just to open up this
file at some point later on um he can
take on f6 so that I just take the
knight on d2 so it takes so I'm just
going to keep opening it up this is why
I said putting this clean on e to wasn't
best because now it's Kingsland h1 so I
maybe played Bishop b5 put some pressure
on it's hanging with the Queen on e2
will be some issues you can always take
on f6 but here I'll just take on d3
right concept of if King wasn't so open
mind you but what is King so open it's
not going to work out very well
now about this with d5 coming next move
having on what he does of course all
right so let's say
Queeny four runs now the hammer Bishop
d5 yeah that's not going to work out so
well for him then to wire like putting
the Queen on you to as much earlier it's
like when I say put the Queen on e to
else inside some units it's very
abstract it's very far out but if
anything ever opens up on the e-file or
the D file something like that you can
have a lot of problems Okafor can just
take the bishop we're going to step into
the King also kind of out of time so I
assume he'll resign here maybe not yeah
alright next game next game who's up
next
um let's see how hard how or no it's not
halberd I accepted it back up I guess
John Ruffolo okay this guy's Adam 20 to
16 so somewhat serious player all the
start with Lancer is a reason I assume
to be getting white against everyone so
far not sure why that is
c4 improbably d 4e 66 so because they
want to go back to the standard theory
on go on to play theory not really
so I'll play b3 I have six Persian b2
can play classic set up III castles
maybe d4 maybe not haven't really
decided what setup I'm going to play um
I'll just play d4 keep it simple make
some sense
d6 interesting okay so he wants to play
something okay I'll just take on d5 d3
he'll probably put a picture on b7 play
494 maybe up five maybe c5 obviously put
a knight on b7 too as well at some point
a pretty standard position so far I'm
going to develop Queen c2 Brooksie one
most likely maybe put pressure on c7
maybe not he can probably prevent any
real pressure on the C file now you go
to c5 I think this is actually a bad
move many which way to play Bishop c2
but II - let me just take the bishop -
[Music]
okay I'll just let him take the bishop I
don't care I'll give them the two
bishops all even with this week on d5
but will be isolated forever I assume
he'll take maybe not see it's okay B now
he gives me this extra temple of Bishop
f5 and you puts the work on c7 and
there's Knight d5 puts over quantity so
694 it's kind of you had to take or put
a knight on e4 because I go into work C
80 game in this extra tempo or so this
works on a a then I could just kick my
bishop with g6 okay so now he goes back
what is which is a completely reasonable
move and now I lost tempo which is the
only problem so now if you go g6 my
knight on d4 not f3 like it would have
been had ayah say fish about five right
away a six
okay decent moves um now I'm going to
try and get strapping and try and create
some big threats along these diagonals
with the fish upon its b2h ap1 h7 maybe
Knight f5 is coming maybe I'll go for
some kind of grand attack
92 93 it all depends how he chooses to
play so he's trying to play hmm
yeah okay I'm going to go for it hey why
not
you only live once maybe hopefully Jesus
moves Bishop f8 also 96 as a move on
probably not the best move because now
he's giving me Megan ville Quincy 294
probably anything is good here but I'm
going to play four attacks and no one
wants to see some dried traditional win
there's no point to that maybe in a
classical game knob woods now maybe
he'll take maybe they were c8 always
there too I use a couple different
possibilities here or wish buffet it
awesome so now I figure out how I'm
going to attack my one of a knight of
520 HP 696 is a move it's very technical
my h5 is also a move I mean I really
just want to attack him I want to attack
him but I can't seem to figure out fine
I'll just take all play I'll play
something boring they'll probably take
with the pawn you should take with the
pond you can take with the rook I want
to take the contacting the knight h5 and
I will see what he does maybe he'll take
maybe you won't put I should pray move
it it's pretty logical let's see what
he's going to do now
seven okay now it's time to go for the
kill I'm gonna go for the kill time to
meet him this is why probably we're
moving this knife from c5 this was bad
in the first place okay g6 I could
exchange cake some small advantage but I
want I want to meet I want to sack on g6
or E or just want a free pawn on e6
probably will go fish about the 8th now
taking I really want to take I can't oh
this is annoying okay and I don't have
any time so that doesn't help okay I'm
gonna have to make this ugly this is
going to be ugly but I'm going to go for
it probably he'll take with the Knight
takes pawn exchange Queens I'm going to
gamble on him not taking with the pond
that I'll take the knight so I can go
Queen h3
with the prima to gain gain a little put
a bit of time obviously I was a terrible
premium it was an hour he was the piece
but he is using a lot of time here so
maybe I can swindle hone maybe maybe
he'll take us a knight he should take
with a bishop but there's still some
hope okay so I kind of message ah
what I meant to do that was very poor
let's see if I can outfit can i flag
this guy
let's see some reason he doesn't want to
move anything
this is so laggy now it's impossible
this is going to be a finish
too much lag oh well how it goes
too much lag too much lag that was
unfortunate okay I'm going to try
someone a little bit better see
there I thought I'd put some I wish I
could see this rating before the game
started but oh well all right
all right so far pretty standard nothing
too exciting I don't know is he being
slow am i lagging something's happening
I ate four okay good milk starting from
playing d5
play Bishop e5 here rook e1 something
along these lines makes no sense 495 X 3
the faction is kind of similar to the
last game white again has an isolated
pawn here on d4 Alaska is on d5 block
hitting on d4 now i'm bought an ominous
blockade like on beef i would a knight
at some point again he should move the
bishop yeah
right b3 h6 probably should move this
page for maybe he'll take not really
clear d2 interesting I'll promote this
last formula worked out so brilliantly
that I must remove again obviously Nighy
for that's a blonder three piece
let's say so
95 again you know maybe worksheet sorry
that's daddy he's down a piece looks a
little bit hard to actually create
anything but the most logical move this
one allows 93 you can see why not to
take a rook probably I'll take that with
a night maybe maybe not not really clear
trades and threats some some simple
smooth victory something like at least
oops oops
not good I'm going to get my Knight's
Cross by taking the pawn but it should
finish off the game a little bit quicker
or else I shall see him right away okay
again I really wish I could see the
rating before the game sir but such is
life so let's see this going to be an
Enzo Enzo Indian Bishop d2 random moves
it'll transpose into something
after a few more moves I think from some
other variation or why puts a bishop on
D to c5
okay so let's sing ah okay here we go
yes
castles um put my knight on either
square alpha on d7 here okay not now I
seem to not be lagging as much - no no
I'm ready to kill
he could play b4 here that actually is a
pretty good move probably on Queen c2 he
wants to play for e4 employee 5 or d4
else play d4 keep it simple try and win
some material here somehow
probably night 84 is objectively best
but also good 94 91 many different moves
here 92 is not one of the moves I was
expecting Val okay build my center up so
he can't break with b4 III also I want
to go e4 next move or c4 Knight c5 long
before night before
okay e4 let's see how to roll everything
okay
really wanted to play b4 so then I can
just place that a slip probably my
turkey too but then I hangs to Bishop
takes e2 anyway
so see what you want to do here probably
93 or be a just down our plane rope goes
it should be over soon okay so now I'm
going to look for someone a little bit
stronger might actually complete stretch
on something pretty DS in here okay
let's see how some of these guys will
feel like if I can play something like
this cláudio 2600 looks pretty decent
I also looks pretty decent okay so I'm
going to play 2580 let's see what you
want to do here okay put a slog I'll
play I'm like four games against or six
games probably four okay six many
different ones will play e3 against the
chub and I'm close chub natural
variation of flaws um let's see it
should be four now that is not the best
move I as far as I seem to recall on
maybe fish past three I'll take Queen b7
on it work a7 I have instead it's line
two long file to see what you ought to
do on out enemies like g4 here maybe
taking g4g for right away probably takes
makes most of solidify the designer
before going in for anything more
probably he'll take back to the pond and
I so efficiently g4 here you like it
what should i plea queenie for maybe we
need for 90 d7 G for 94 or I can just
play something boring like we should be
2 or f3 on 396 I mean I really don't
want to play boring so all what to do
what to do what to do okay I'll play
Queen Anne squirrel let's see how he's
going to block with a block with the
night or the bishop probably night DD 7
probably but not not completely sure
that's what I expected now this would be
five move f3 is also move I think I like
us through the most
okay we're gate now I can go g4 here it
was point behind up three I kind of want
to put some pressure on him because he
hasn't dissolved to play Brooke eight
seven rook e8 so he lost to Tempe he on
yeah
he hasn't developed anything on its
king's head over here so he probably
wants to go g6
to develop those bitter p7 can always
play h4 I don't I don't know the h4
accomplishes anything but I kind of like
it so it looks cool doesn't mean it's
any good obviously but looks cool
because if you guys g6 I want to go h5
some Bishop few seven I have aged six
okay when you go to the h6 now by going
age six I'm just going to go h5 so you
can't go g6 and fee on Cairo as bishop
so now like if he takes on as promised
this bishop on e6 is so terrible it just
it's thoughts and from playing ee6 and
this whole King side is kind of like
shut down I am it's just kind of ugly
really I expected this but now on 97
which I think his plan was with b4 that
I can't go out Forks he'll take the pawn
but but now I think I'll play for
position I can go Queen and actually
know why even play positionally a let's
play Queen a for play for a play for the
initiative right right away because he
still hasn't dissolved anything over
here so he's still into trouble and open
94 who's looking really nice
you
King d8 now that's a nozzle Anubis I
ever saw one um okay how rusted okay
I'll just take this bishop no no need to
know need to be fancy because now the
problem also is when he takes with the
pod he's got this problem that the
bishop in the long term is also kind of
dead-on on f8 which is a rather serious
issue for black here like a really
serious issue in fact this is like some
kind of really terrible version of like
a caro-kann or something of course I do
stuff to be careful but if I can get the
bishop to g6 he can never play cheat six
and now his bishop is dead forever as
actress's rook on h8 so now he wants to
want to open it do I really want to give
him that I all just take it anyway I'm
not too concerned all types played
exchanged all the pieces that in the
long term his Fishman is work here or
gone forever this is pretty ugly okay
actually took I'll take I want to go
Queen c4 Queen c2 put pressure on on his
weak Hans probably he'll go clean in d5
I would guess probably maybe not maybe
I'll go Queen d3 but anyway this is all
pretty uh I could take the pawn on e4 I
don't really care though I just want to
go King up to work c1 and made him on a
C file a little bit late to the party
with rook c8 trying to free his bishop
and now I have many different ways to
win I'm going to go for this because
then it's the neatest way and now it's
working as fish for dead forever
basically it's a pretty brutal way to
lose a game
yeah and I'll just tick off this pawn on
b4 and I think that's probably it's
going to resign here yawns kind of what
I expected
I just rematch them I'll fall play I
think I'll plant it for games give them
a shot let's see what he's going to do I
have 3d 6 this would be 7 play cleans
Indian something a little bit different
for this game at least on the rupee -
Bishop e7 probably Hill Castle probably
maybe not not really sure I'd see 394 is
salt
no I'm Theory probably Bishop b2 maybe
the queen - - maybe we'll take ya house
it's recently actually against a hammer
92 slightly different on hammer play
Knight each for guns for me what do I
want to do it here you want to play c5
how do I want to test the center here or
d5 also deeper looks reasonable I know I
want to play something more interesting
so play for c5 just to keep it a little
bit more involved probably I'll play d5
I would expect can also just move is
nice act to f3
you could also take I guess those in
release it's not really in spirited
position but it's a move it's all take
takes 9:00 to 6:00
probably Queen D 324 something like that
this is unfortunately very dry or get
rid of the weak pawn maybe three outs
I'll play boring boring just a very
boring end game my decide rose in
advance
probably Bishop d2 but maybe I can play
this rustic while any of these four are
not very exciting though try to create
something he put them in shrine up
forwards a little bit weird um probably
should not have done that he probably
should have put on d2x now maybe I can
get f65 create some kind of center a
little bit on before definitely does not
look right though cuz now I'm going to
go out now I'm going to threaten 82 and
overnight d3 but we'll see
it's going to go a3 783 probably work CA
I'll bring with this one last remove
work well on but see if I going to
review and now he seeds the full see
file to me so I can go eat five I can
also go work see to repeat to allows 91
but it looks advocacy for was also
possible um I don't know I like Brooks
etudes now he'll probably have to go 91
91 Ricky one maybe Bishop c5 um before
definitely does not look right I think
he's starting to lose the thread a
little bit um but still he is 94 threats
so I should probably I'll kick his
Bishop back I don't really like it don't
feel them feel quite right but try and
create some pressure on this Queen side
here okay one okay so this is one of the
work do you want or not I don't know if
he actually wants to go work up to you
on here or he doesn't but I'll double
and see filed seems like logical logical
move probably I'll go broke d1 I was
going to go Bishop si no I think I'll go
work c7 I really want to go for Knight B
to 94 and not give them this d7 square
for the rook that was bad or was it I
guess it was and I still I still nice to
one to hang on but I forgot to the
adrift e2 in all fairness so I'm
probably worth t5 maybe knife eatery ver
p1 and I have not this is not really
what I wanted but okay I'll also climb
down on time to so I kind of need just
start moving faster I could have gone
receipt for also was available writing
all improve my king de 6 then go for
work before try to create some threats
now I'll try and put some pressure on
tonight on D to hang up 394 maybe hang
up one is still here King off one you
can go review one I'll just take it and
now I'm going to try to do something
here fix the pawns on dark squares here
so he can't do anything
of course I do don't really have
anything special here ins kind of very
maybe old butter with a for I doubt it
but
okay we'll see one okay fine I'll just
take is going to have to flag plaque the
sky probably Oh play Roxy - yeah that's
not really how I wanted to win this but
oh well can't cut lucky all the time but
what's the time like um I'm going to get
it done
yeah well that was disappointing to say
the least yeah that was frustrating that
was very frustrating all right I'll
plant a few more games I'll play two
more now I'll give him a chance to prove
that he can play this line a little bit
better than last time
um well we played Bishop g4 really flew
any other lines not really sure okay
wants lead e5b through the main well I'm
going to try and place me a little bit
weird to trick him in fact I think this
this is actually going to turn into a
lot something very small asking me last
we miss Bishop you for Queen b3 Nani had
the option B 5 here is B 5 c 5m Bishop
you force is very similar that's
actually known to be quite bad for black
I believe after 95 our minds saying I
think it was known this is known to be
quite bad to black because now after 97
I'd see six no matter which 90 blocks
will actually see six is just crushing
trying to be the queen for all the sleep
Bishop d2 I'll probably Bishop d6 I
would guess or beats up and not
really sure I want to play Queen a 4/4
for some kind of end game I got really
so thrilled by any of this but it's just
just probably 96 Queen b3 maybe a 4
maybe not
okay Queen b8 I don't maybe wants to do
the Fisher Fisher gambit take on h2 just
go for something for c6 put some
pressure on on all his pieces since
they're so discombobulated as night as
bishop because York's Queen some point I
want to go eat for I've just just
waiting for the right for a moment
moment may have just arrived yeah I
think it did I'll go for e4 open up some
great more space on diagonals open up
everything and now he grabs the pawn now
I know he does ground okay interesting
I'm also sure this is scary this is
actually good though
sure this looks pretty bad probably just
take on e6 blacks King is maybe slightly
safer but his pieces all his kids are on
the back rank so it's hard to believe
you can have anything here rook e8 no I
don't want to go d5 I would be terrible
let's just 57 maybe
I have six who wants to go a 95 I guess
I really don't want to let him get that
but okay so if I move my rook he has 95
night of for play d5 use queen five I
play I can also just take I guess I
don't really want to do this let's say
okay one thirty amp still up a little
bit of time on the clock okay Queens
before just stop 95 I don't see any
direct threat city has here it's like
seem to move this rook somehow if I can
if I can remove my rook then I will be
in great shape
okay so it would be 1706 if you take on
b5 then I take up seven it takes the
rook I take as work on ei which I think
he'll do that would make the most sense
actually takes the rook and I take a 95
Queen 86 trick so I actually just lost
here
okay they plays where fe5 probably just
tape with the rook if six Bishop d2 King
G tha work f8 so he's pretty much in a
lot of trouble so it should just be
winning those work chief sighs I don't
really want to take maybe I can just go
d5 threatened made on each for throne
Queen h4 swinging across to meet him
maybe you had something here but oka
just resigned so I'll give them one more
game and then I'll move on and this game
I won't play Queens gambit declined or
Queen's Indian sorry I'll play something
else
um let's go for let's play dodge
something that Simon Williams would
would be proud although actually he
plays the he plays a stone wall which is
not what I play but I'll try it anyway
why not what's the worst that can happen
maybe I'll lose I would be such a crime
I guess III um I want to play d5 C 55 go
on yeah why not go for it
course a normal interpreter night on you
for probably at some point on probably
go be six fish basics or be six there
should be subbing depending on what his
setup is dish about four point ninety
four you can always take the bishop
I'll just take back and then probably I
shouldn't have played this this line
because it's actually quite easy for
what I could blockade the whole position
which means the draw is more likely on
but easier easier easier said now then
it would have been an earlier a takes
I'll take 95-97 exchange nights this is
again looking pretty garage
unfortunately s4f for interesting so I
can take I don't have to I don't put be
six this is interesting so I take he
takes it upon a fiber key one I don't
have anything on the other hand the d6
before you excited a 458 I think I'll
play something different try and open up
the Queen side over here a little bit
probably hopefully before I would assume
sort of expect at least not that old
necessarily oh he doesn't want okay so
he doesn't want to play like that okay
interesting in that case he'll play
barfi eight in due to normal normal
looking move I don't really want to take
but I don't see anything better really
so I'll just do it wait that would that
was actually very poor cream he could
have taken to pawn but realistically
never was so it's not that bad of a
cream of I guess
unfortunately as I said before the
structure does not lend itself to
exciting games so probably going to be
more than likely it's going to be a draw
here I don't think either of us can
really do a whole lot my toys definitely
better but a little bit hard to do
anything okay
fortunately I don't really have many
options so I'm just going to sit back
and chill see what you want to do I
don't know if he's listening to the
broadcast only trying to offer me draw
I'm not going to give them a draw
trying to do something over here on the
kingside maybe not really sure what but
they'll try and do something trying to
swindle on somehow okay times time to
attack
one probably I'm going to try and swing
my recorder to that file now Bishop g4
rookie seven maybe he'll play out five
maybe not it's hard decision here and
you can not what I would do but let's
say nope it's not literally five trying
to exchange some rooks you play for h5
at some point maybe depending what he
does probably he'll exchange but I'm not
sure so probably will take it upon Yan
I'm going to try and put a rock on g7 go
age five or something I try and attack
him although it's going to be a little
bit hard see here you can go through a
ch3
I got again he's turtling although you
just like cleanup tool on bish page five
so now it might actually get something
probably not that I'm I've got to try
probably h3 maybe not let's try and play
something super aggressive try and
really open area up here
see what I can make work although I've
already got something but by being able
to play C 5 and open up this structure
it's become something much more serious
than it ever should create 522 mono my
king
if I've probably makes sense just make
sure there are no targets here so that I
can just play normal move see what you
want to do now go fighting do some kind
of
see okay that's going to be sometimes
big time scramble although here I am
push my age on down the board
Oh what was keen be one
oops I was a big time scramble okay I'll
give them two more two more on that day
last two if you can define the flaws
last to note this guy and then I'll
probably go back splints more normal
guys again I'm not not sure but too hard
playing these top guys although I think
Daniel is somewhere maybe maybe he's
gone again I don't know
although actress it's summer times he's
not he's not at a college
alright guys sure love to play b5 I've
noticed everywhere he's playing it g6
without II took the compute for and now
the deep tank g6 um this might be some
kind of obscure theory action I'll I
think about it um not certain Oh mind
you know and then it'd be 7f for
probably he'll take I would assume f6
interesting you can go e5 here I mean
I'm probably going to do FIV for I'm not
I'm not sure if I'm going to do that but
it makes some sense I can also just move
the bishop I mean I'd rather
unattractive but you force the moves
that makes sense but I'm just going to
be boring
so there's your back giving me for play
Knight d2 probably play off five
something along these lines
so probably hopefully a five minute then
I think I'm going to go fish for a three
I think that's my plan I mean I can also
do some sacks here but I think I'm just
going to play Bishop a3 keep it simple
probably he should take but he might not
he might he might go he might go for
something else too
right so that I think was a mistake
because now I can take on a five and I
can he's never going to be able to keep
the Queen side completely closed right
so I can play nice b3 BC 395 c b2
reasonable the play nice b3 first you
can also just move this clean so it
doesn't really make a difference always
put the knight back first fish raised
six probably low exchange I would assume
mean six of an interesting what is he
trying to do
okay I'll just castle I'll just let an
exchange when he wants to keep dissolved
in basically I want to play against open
up this Queen so at some point a3 a4 do
something over here for you can recruit
completely on I might not be able to do
that but with correctly I probably have
nothing here but prior to play as a term
that you definitely don't use for blitz
I'm going to move my knight to home put
a bush Bundy - he's trying to attack me
over here I actually didn't realize to
to do that Oh include a chicken it's
like what is he doing - trying to uh
he's going to go h5 I'm gonna go night
b1 only danger here is that all my
pieces are on the Queen side but I'm not
too worried here since he played rotates
out that means he's going to go over Kay
he's not going to play age five age four
and try and kill me on the Kings side um
so it said that I'm gonna flip D to put
pressure on this pond probably night c1
maybe or just move my queen attack upon
vocal reason well I probably wish
tonight mv1 somehow doesn't look quite
right whole city and we will say indeed
you're starting to think a lot now
emailed explained I see one could now be
case all taken when takes I take moves
at night I can move my bishop to protect
the rook on b2 okay so he really doesn't
want to you want to do this but now wait
why did I just play a three and just
take what was that that was kind of
stupid that was really kind of stupid
that was completely unintentional is
just a blunder I guess I'll just play
some kind of end game now unfortunately
I guess he offered me another drawer or
something as usual I'm going to give
them a draw not in this position for
sure no not what I can get pieces on the
right squares probably clean a four but
then I got 92 maybe or a misplay bore
and King up one King e1 Queen D 1 it may
make sure it's Queen on a 4 is
uncomfortable
now if it goes back I can go like in
situ and Knight a 2 or something
[Music]
probably gonna play 96 here or not or
you can put like this now now he's
getting himself into a little bit
trouble though because Queens going to
end up passive or not he's going to play
like this ok Wow
I'd see - how did you protect a pawn
here 95 93 how does he protect this pawn
I don't think he does ok so you see a
squadron put the knight on d4 in hope
but his pieces are all a little bit
misplaced here so I'm going to play
Knight a to trap dominate the knight of
d3 is no squares anymore exchange of
bishops bring the knife back to c4 I
want to go now but my not rd6 now his
pieces are weak too
probably he'll go kinesics again soon
yeah his pieces are his nights are bad
also so it's like matter of whose night
is for responded whose nights whose
knife is nights on its own kind of weird
pun we can go a 95 now but his night on
d3 it looks really pretty but it's not
actually doing anything so I didn't
expect me to go back to be four okay
and getting awfully weird I don't know
why I did that I shouldn't I shouldn't
have taken on c6 but it's still probably
winning this just not quite how I want
to play this about 94 night takes off 5s
as pawns are too weak and of course
again I make a terrible pre move
let's see if I can win this
and did I win it even with the lag I won
this that was pretty bad
that was not that's not one of the
greatest hits that was definitely not
one of the greatest hits
okay I'll good let's go one more and
that's it
okay c4l plays c6 I guess basically a
bit different again this time as well
let's see um she doesn't opening yeah
those last two games are pretty close by
laughing especially he a little bit too
slow I'm at the very on D he should have
run with the King closer to the center
but I mean easier said than done
in the heat of the moment it was kind of
turning some kind of English maybe I'm
not sure who he does play something some
kind of box in it or something probably
he'll take maybe maybe not not sure
probably 92y c5 slid on enough for I can
meet a four with up five and and then he
doesn't get the get the break that you
want probably will try and play a 3 B 4
I mean or it'll just go up for the
probably up for is now it's bishops
closed his diagonals no longer open so
um you had some problems here so he's
gonna play Bishop b2 I don't know if
taking us a right little but it looks
looks like a reasonable move at least
for all play page 3 probably
hopefully Ricky one maybe or woke up to
the computer would it be a very bad mood
when I just exchange the most like he'll
move the rook and obviously Queen d7
want to go Ricky eight next move or
Bishop f5 fine really forced exchange of
the bishops after Bishop f5 on they get
the struck five end example of awake so
hang upon eerie please be for not too
worried about this cuz after attacks
upon team d3 or work through one I just
go b6 lookin so it goes back now I'm
going to put a night on e 3 and the
problem here is the official passes nice
passes all these kids are very fast and
he has weaknesses here well my solution
trusted dreams by going to work up to
now I can't even take the night on e3
excite equip upon so Queen b3 do I want
to play tickle Hummer now I'll play work
he says I could have gotten a chief for
the force which g2 with Ricky six still
can't take threatening work a six you
slate clean
hangs in exchange so this is probably
just going to lose pretty pretty quickly
on a piece again there so Pathak here's
it and it's really stuck in a bad spot
I'll try and open it up more b5 takes
I'll take with a queen probably just
open up everything since I do an extra
exchange and when you have you have an
extra exchange you definitely want to
open up the open up files for your rooks
III bring my bishop into the game now as
well on many different possibilities
I'll just click Queen before seems like
as a reasonable move as any move early
so let's take probably worth d3 I'll
mostly Ricky 293 Rafi to anyway so the
item is pretty pretty much lost for
white let's see th-three
fighting on I appreciate the spirit of
Queen 6o h g4 h 5u displays Queen Queen
Casey - whoops whoops whoops whoops I'm
going to sharpen out all of the rook
wow this movie or play for h5 next move
trying to exchange some more stuff on a
king side we're not three I'll play h5
for sure announce on f5 I can just take
on g4 and he does something else
oh let's see
two three I can play queen g4 I think
I'll just throw in c4 is extra tempo
person C can play f5 on this extra tempo
maybe actually I just quit c3 come
Bishop c3 rookie three is just game over
yeah it goes it's just over so alright
five the last gasp I'll throw in a check
fish for work f4 or I can take a rope on
83 I'll just take this one something up
for everybody five I mean taking the
rook on a three results completely fine
of course but they both work alright so
let's say so who's up next let's see um
I want to play this guy earlier where'd
he go yeah one okay so let's say it's
okay so I'll play Knight of three I two
new playing Knight of 3 C 4 9 3 D for
every game so why not
b5 I'm going to play a bank oh it's a
cool opening and with an extra tempo it
has to be a really cool opening probably
he'll take on e3 although actually I
said time for this actually much closer
to the Blumenthal yeah but which
normally colors here reverse goes
something like d4 Knight to c4 c5 d v e6
Knight of three men b5 so it's kind of
reversed Blumenthal's I have an extra
tempo on so let's see so probably he'll
take D for baseline attacking pawns here
give them I'll give them an extra pot on
the queenside but at the same time I
want to create this big center over here
I know the a3 is right I could play
Queen eight four also possible but I
just feel like playing traditional
probably he'll take you I would expect
them to take I'll take with the bishop
play Knight c3 castles pretty standard
stuff so far
so off tonight c3e to Queenie - maybe x3
do something create something here in
the center
is figure out hard results you want to
sleep Bishop three four and change a
bishop for the nightly b6 Bishop d7 this
is also reasonable although I think
slightly wrong I'm not quite sure how do
I exploit this efore fish b75 maybe I'll
go for it why not try just really
exploit the center here because I'm
Bishop e7 plate for a 5 on just play 94
I can do a 95 maybe gonna have to I mean
I can just play pure yeah but style I
mean like pure like Joe Bob of style
display e5 and just just give a free
exchange on why not I'll just go for it
there are no reason to hold back
probably 93 Queen e2 takes work f1 this
would be 7 and maybe d5 or bush before
but basically to Obama style okay
keeping the tank now so let's see what's
going to do 96 that seems like a strange
mood which before
kind of strange I don't know I'm not a
big fan of this idea now I can also just
move my queen on III D - D - runs into
page six
probably Queen D three I think I'm
holding everything together I don't
think he can sack on e5 um he can but
that doesn't seem like the best try so
yeah and so I see someone just said I'm
not not in my chat on my channel um so
so yeah so I just popped up in a
toggling I'm not actually toggling I
don't
oh did I actually open that in the wrong
window what's my mistake sorry um I
shouldn't I hope not in the wrong window
oh let me let me focus on winning this
game first and right on that was a
mistake
I'll play h3 attack that
okay so now let's see okay I'm going
take the night always there I really
want to play d5 and just crushing the
center but it's not really there right
now so I'm just going to play all moose
get up
so we put Knight a 5 mm probably yeah
now I'm going to get what I want kind of
I mean I'll take my 95 something like
this at least make it pretend that it
looks good I'm glad I've got a bunch of
knights in the center how bad can it be
it looks really good even though it's
probably not um I can do this I don't
really want to but I'll do it it makes
sense
so yeah okay f6 because I am getting a
little low on time lower than I'd like
to be dishonest play like more on
traditional put the 93 play d5 seat bud
so these bad pieces on the kingside the
night here this Bishop I mean they're
all a little bit a little bit kind of
misplaced here so c5 seems like a good
try Knight f5 I could take I sell to not
take obviously t5d five courts not to
watch my time as I'm talking too much
again arms okay 94 probably 96 not sure
86 all good g4 194 all this take always
take and I'll just take all the 93 and
Bishop here on on the squared so
horrendous I think they just take Queen
a3 Queen shoot for and I think he is
kind of lost maybe b-52h one I think you
can't do much here
all right so let's see so okay um who
will I play next someone else die natur
81 maybe or not so I thought except from
yeah yeah okay so so as I've seen before
um yeah so I am back in the chat as well
I'm not a I'm uh I am fact I chatted
playing as well so I might see some of
some of the comments and I'm gonna see a
lot of them because most people I play
I'm not gonna be able to spot them again
eight and a half on the clock I learned
my lesson about spotting guys on the
clock earlier today when I lost to that
at 2100 guy so alright let's see so so
far because there it goes and I'll play
Queen b3 many moves Queen a4 is move
Bishop c5 e 3 CD 5 all over they're all
pretty decent Queen b3 of course also a
move yeah let's stop look at the chat
when I started saying things like camp
can't spot can't spot time on the clock
to 1300 you know well maybe in this game
I can not not all the game anyway
alright so let's see
so probably castles here taking on see
through is not the best move Theory
black schools probably see five of
computer the bust move to castles this
was classically I probably use 10 15
minutes trying to figure out why this is
so dubious that in blitz game I don't
have the luxury so I'll just play some
normal moves
um probably he'll take care maybe not
not really sure
let's see if they sinking here see five
good move hey does that actually
transpose back into something isn't
exactly some kind of area if I'm not
mistaken but we will see if it's 85
smelt a goose night probably supposed to
take the queen up north again he's not
going to just seeing that it hangs the
d5 pawn c4 is not correct I can just
take them and just move my fish for ways
I'm going to move to e7 so let's see
what you going to do here all right so
let's see so rookie a push Bay three
the a - I can take the pawn I'll just
ignore I'll play III play something more
on the develop my pieces first once they
can always take this palm later it's
using to do here and one of my one oh
man why don't what am i when I looked
down off the side I'm just looking at my
phone looking at some some skype
messages um I just got a message from
someone who works your chest column they
asked if I want to play them an odds
game on the stream on I think I think I
will so I'll always tell after this game
and all lesson start the game I'll
explain more about that in sacrimoni
cynosure off this game for us okay
a six there should be four see what it's
going to do
okay here we go so I'm going to play two
games against this guy I'm giving him
three piece odds I even creates these
odds
see I think about two weeks ago maybe um
and I beat him too and I would think I'd
be in two and a half one and a half I
think it was um I think I won two games
he won one we drew two so I'm going to
try and beat him like three plus two
let's see what he can do
I'm going to be very fast of course
because if I'm not fast mean you do too
much time to exchange pieces or things
then that I'm going to end up losing
pretty badly so I've got to be kind of
fast I also make sure he is no clearer
path he is no like super clear ideas
about how to play like here not
committing to castling I'm leaving all
my pawns here in the center I'm waiting
for them to decide which way is going to
cap so most likely I'm gonna go the
other way if he goes long I'll probably
go short go short if he go short I'll
probably go long just to increase the
odds of something happening of course
you just played 92 which is kind of
annoying he wasn't supposed to play like
that but he took on c5 he didn't go see
three so there is some hope still okay
so you please see for all I can take on
b2 I guess I don't know if I want to but
yeah I'll take it upon us upon after all
it does matter and now he can't go long
so he's gonna have to go short and
having played h4 he might be hesitant
now two castles when Susanna city's
getting attacked as well so what we'll
see we'll see how he's going to play
this but so far it's looking pretty good
E has no his ideas are not super obvious
I mean they are obvious enough they're
not super obvious and it's just so much
stronger they would just a country v I
don't expect them to however so just
leave issues before now I can go be
sighs and if you move special I'm going
to go see for trap the bishops on it's
one piece back already
ooh rookie sorry whoa getting getting
aggressive man getting aggressive what
is this that was not uh that's what I
see because now I mean he still has I
guess he has still three pieces for for
my rook but it's not clear what he's
doing and again he's going to be he's
going to be hesitant to Castle King
Felix is going to see that I've got g4
type moves a pawn is hanging there are a
lot of different things here I mean I
want to take on a tube that he takes my
takes my pawn on c5 any checkmates me
rook a to Bishop takes d5 points five
Queen d8 with checkmate so I kind of
have to move my king and avoid that kind
of nonsense if we play to a4 I'll put my
king over in the corner maybe they would
treat for next move probably just move
this rook first before I do anything
else probably he'll put I don't know
what else oh maybe we'll play e5 put a
bishop on d3 attack me with EE sighs not
not entirely sure this is best way to
play for him I mean probably it's more
realistic sacrifice bishop for some
ponds and it sacrifice on the sacrifice
of rook and now he's going just crazy I
don't know why he's doing this it's
always great when when William when you
when it works near the hero of one it
doesn't work it's you definitely not not
going to be a hero today man so um I
mean it's already given back to pieces
and in fact I'm not even sure I was
playing a really good player it would
still be better for why pitting on
someone who's a little bit weaker I'm
already not sure this is what I would
even consider this to be better for them
if they had the white pieces here you
got a really strong player of course
what would still be much better but this
is getting him getting a little bit
tricky I played Queen c5 he has to block
Queen or he can walk into this now it's
getting really ugly
getting ugly in a hurry still is Knight
G one he's still fighting kind of um I
mean fighting is a general way but I
mean he's going to go King III and I
don't have to play cleaning one but I
just want to play Queen one for
to an end game I figure probably I
actually wanted without any issues just
a clean exchange here
so team v2 although my record a 1 and
I'm just in fact somehow I've ended up
just up an exchange here for this we've
got two ponds on ok i fives a good move
what's the best way to play off this
check and throw in a check
you can check you might as well so in d3
I'll throw in another track maybe he
goes Kingston or maybe not or or you can
go to me - rookie - but this has not
worked out the way that I think he was
hoping it would have poor Pete probably
came out for e5q for I mean still can
hope this is not this is not really what
I think he was hoping for at all I'm
teenage Trina I do it to be slightly
careful this canopy it does get me
needed to up 6
so can you 790 15 up 6 losing I waking
up 6 and yeah so yes nothing here so
he's in a lot of trouble now because my
Kings on 6 I'm going to swing the door
tha will check next move and it will
have all worked out beautifully
Oh 97 good try he wanted a 95 with me
but unfortunately I have this check
first and after Kings before there are a
couple ways I can play I think I'll just
play to say if we just exchange the
rooks
I'll allow any shenanigans here like
teenage 5 I take 3 I think he walked in
to meet one so that was an ideal
okay round two again on a cliff name
setups if I had a light square bishop I
would put I would put it on a TL I would
put on the diagonal to like play this
Bishop on CI to go b6 Bishop d7 as well
I'm previously as I try to e6 and Bishop
moving the pitch on is on the f8 beef a3
diagonal on this diagonal plan they were
always able to put a bunt d3 and
there was too much pressure along a lot
longest side long diagonal towards age
seven on my king so I kind of abandoned
that idea so let's see if I can win
again so he's probably gonna play it's
very similar setup on I'll kind of play
the similar like waiting game and we'll
see what he does on basically the points
to just make sure there are no obvious
targets make sure the game goes on
unfortunately it's 95 here which I
forgot about but he didn't see it so
that's always a good start
please 94 I guess I have to go teenage
12 and I don't really want to but I kind
of have to just hang in there just
protect as much as I can rook e1 could
be a rather serious problem but I'll try
and hang on with d5 the dish beige six
I'll just take the knight if you check
okay he didn't check it out I didn't
move like oh why did I go there fish
before that was not fast
I mean I'm running ways in which white
is winning here hopefully doesn't find
any of them they please c3 and it's
going to be a bit tough here I'm in -
hang on
we'll be extraordinary if I can just
because it's not only that I am down
peace but everything's a little bit open
I have a problem avoiding exchanges that
is going to be a big problem here like
here I'm actually - update now I've got
things like 90 X 5 all kinds of ugliness
coming or cleanup for this one I
probably won't hold on it but I'm going
to try maybe I can get lucky here maybe
I wouldn't count
honest and maybe need to be in the work
very unlikely I would say here Emily
it's just two positions to static if
there's maybe one piece and it was like
the kind of structure I like to ride but
with three pieces there's almost no way
and let's he just like goes insane and
hang something so this would be at three
so I got to try and break the structure
create something not going to work
obviously okay so he played c4 so he's
trying to get a little bit creative here
I'm not I mean he's obviously winning
but messing up a structure while it's
still winning I mean you never know he
could he could always take with the
Queen here on d4 for example not that I
expect him to but he could and he did oh
he did he told for it
I don't believe this oh I don't believe
this he fell for it now this is going to
get interesting that's maybe like four
pieces against the Queen this is going
to be very interesting I mean obviously
it's completely lost but I do have a
queen and he only has four pieces only
four pieces after all four pieces is not
a lot you need more than four pieces to
beat a queen I'm being facetious of
course you do not need more than four
pieces depite a queen but but at least I
have a fighting shot now I mean I didn't
I did not have a fighting shop before
but there's always a chance he could
hang something here because it's like
the pieces are really close together
here but he could hang something I
wouldn't say it's impossible I need to
get him a little bit lower on time but
like even lose the Knight to e5 or
something then he walks into like Queen
d2 check or clean up for tracker there
there are some tricks here so it's not
it's not reveal um I don't know how to
promise how do I create anything I'm
going to try cleanup forest kind of
dangerous to put my queen in the middle
here with all these pieces in the center
here and all these Forks around it but
okay so play Bishop c6 so I'm going to
go to f7
see if maybe he'll check me on
the six I'm not not actually sure 9066
maybe I mean I'm trying to find is it to
make sure I don't get my queen and
actually might clean far away from my
king and I have to make sure you can't
just made me with the four pieces I can
basically all there is to it and so it's
it's a 95 song to play tnow so if I'm
basically just keep it far away and hope
that he's won or something of course if
he just keeps all his pieces clustered
together there's nothing I can do I mean
I can't tick off a piece but you know I
can't pick off a piece I'm going to get
some get some checks now let's take a
look pick up a pawn in a two there is
some some some big possibilities that I
can swindle now because it's going to be
hard to sleeve your pieces here in the
center of the board do nothing so it
won't fit before I'll go King e6 again
just sticking with the theme of keeping
my king like super far away from my
queen is kind of all I can do here I
could have gone King d6 I mean this is
very of course very tricky obviously
this is probably losing somehow but I'm
going to try and I can check him see
what he does he's going to go for a draw
no he doesn't he doesn't want to draw
now I'm going to go I'm going to go to
meet him I'm gonna play Queen g3 and
made him very as I said before is
dangerous having the Queen so close to
the king learn all kinds of dangers of
forks but I don't actually see any Forks
right now and if you check for bikini
for maybe qg6 it's very iffy but it was
not h4 to be so careful here not to get
not to walk into a fork it's like insane
okay so keen be sick
he has night at 5:00 here Kimsey 7 okay
so he goes there and put my queen closer
may be able to check and just very hard
to play the one thing I do have is them
up on a clock now so I'm up on the clock
and now he let me get any 85 so now it's
game on because he like he let me
activate my Mac and now I'm not a
counter play for sure whether he can
hold on and not I mean Louis's now
actually really the question whoops that
was a slip I meant to go b3 but yeah
let's see okay so now I'm going to now
I'm going to roll up on b3 maybe you can
play nice before I mean I did a wrong
Claire would still hold this quite
easily but he doesn't have any time and
Knight b6 now is night out of play
there's no harmony there um me Bishop e5
is tricky so I'm not completing the oven
maybe I have to run with my king closer
again I don't really like doing this but
I'll probably check me or night before
I'll play Queen Seaforth Knight a5 King
teeny 5 fish cross 4
I'll go team c5 only is 96 checks and 98
16 b6 and now his pieces are all out of
play they're all like not harmonized
Knights are on both c6h4 and not what a
passed pawn um and this I appreciate or
no Queen C efficient before it's always
tricky but I don't think you can stop me
here from queening queening cleaning a
second pawn at least I don't think you
can okay Bishop d2 I go b4 and I mean
finding is with even without these uh
even I think if you're in this position
probably without Knight f5 was probably
still kind of okay maybe for it based on
practical plan
not actually sure but just out of pieces
okay so who next Oh Cal plays nice ooh
for Auckland I have six books to ease
into c-46 probably I see three there
should be four playing on some kind of
an Enzo Oh Castle he2
pretty much identified c5g 548 b6 even
probably is okay so this is just pretty
standard b5 see these five I can take
either way I'll just take look upon for
the moment probably e 2 I would
expect um yeah I 96 maybe or I can play
h6 both modes are reasonable I'll play
something a little bit more interesting
more creative ultra 94 maybe he'll take
maybe he won't take on it doesn't take
so egg and IX just develop fish about
five next move probably fish about five
rook c8 along these lines of this was
probably my plan okay someone in the
tractor said play AB on cloud I don't
know what opening that is okay um
someone can probably enlighten me on
that topic
alright so Bishop e6 I'm probably gonna
go Knight a5 rook c8 are put pressure on
these these week on this week c3 pawn if
I can get a Knight to c4 that's pretty
good at the same time I don't know any
weaknesses over here so what is two
bishops the White has some pawn two over
here that aren't perfectly placed so
looking good so far Queen d3 I'll click
Queen d7 just so that I can play Bishop
a5 and and tickle this Queen here on d3
if I need to I also can also threaten to
play Bishop g4 maybe for sex change the
light square Bishop s' with h3 I'll go
back to the original plan play Knight a5
now
um so what the bond cloud is efore key -
okay I'll keep that in mind for uh for
another game okay Queen d2 nice p3c so I
just want to exchange her Knight a 100k
one I'll take a pawn here on c3 um so
it's already pretty pretty bad I don't
think it's so much the way I can do here
so next time I want to play AB on cloud
it gets
assuming they cooperate I don't I don't
know what they can maybe a fun place a
45 I can't really do it or efore Knight
f6 but I get someone who doesn't do that
then I'll I'll try it I'll try it oh
I'll try it and I'll see if it works out
and guy says I would donate five dollars
for a bond cloud game okay you guys okay
crease up for evergage three eyes this
will be over soon well well get well
we'll get we'll get to see we'll get to
do some funny it's funny opening pretty
soon I think seriously wants to trap my
rook here on I can just bring it back
each six bring it back to ISA source e6
put it just put on e6 double on the
e-file sexy one
I'll play work c6 no I work you six is
fine too but I don't feel like giving
even counter-plan if I can exchange
rooks here with the rook against the
bishop it's pretty pretty bad and the
bishop here isn't doing anything it's
not attacking any piece of this planet
sitting here in the corner all along
okay so I wish pg3 all the slave sex no
no need to go crazy I'll try and finish
this off pretty quickly so I can playing
the bongo huh I'll play Ricky - probably
all go King age three here I would
assume many different ways of playing so
I think I'll just put the Queen on d5
very small loops off the pause member of
pushing from coming down the board get
the check but basically no real counter
play turn up what I want to do or I'll
play x5k I'll just take upon g5 as
always a move I guess mostly g6 it goes
clean up six hopefully clean six force
an exchange of the Queen's and I my work
will just beat the bishop in the I'm
game
maybe you can go keen eh for maybe maybe
not not really clear um Queen c7 I can
tinker I can check
I like check more shot KH Faurot engage
for maybe I can play this really cute
really cute idea rookie for when he
takes I've Queen G for checkmate so oh
and you're resigned before you do it
that's disappointing
this is not where I wanted if I didn't
want to play bullet I've always cooked
in the other game all right one second
let's see let's it was the next next
challenge from reload over there we go
okay here we go
efore is going to cooperate he is going
to cooperate let's see it and now he's
all confused I think but let's see
thanks man
[Laughter]
okay so far I've got it actually I have
a position that's not to LA so that's
already a good accomplishment all things
consider I'm not really sure how I'm
going to improve my position I can put
it working one that's not actually turn
into something resembling a decent
position don't even ask me why but it
has even though it should not have I
mean if I can get this position every
game maybe I would start playing the
blonde cloud but I don't think I'm going
to get this latke moved to the time okay
before put my king on the square it was
supposed to be on in the first place
probably he'll take I'll take BC three
this position looks pretty decent 97 I
don't know if d4 is the best move but
I'll try it
most likely he'll exchange up c3 and
then before maybe not and then I get it
on so he did okay so he took I'll take
back need a queen bee 653 yeah this is
worked out really well that's a good
opening I should play them often really
good opening okay so Queen B 3 so
actually this is weird this guy is like
trying to eyes trying to play like
normal trapped against me you're trying
to play as solid as you can it was very
very strange considering the first two
moves that I made so probably 94 maybe
not that would make the most sense but
still even after night before I'm doing
completely fine night before maybe push
press 293 rookie three days King up to I
mean black is maybe slightly better but
nope nothing more I would think okay oh
okay one the laws 94 probably not quite
right I can try e5 I know if I want to
it all go for it I'm going
before I do a fish about one maybe I
think it's what I'll do just play Bishop
up one force exchange yeah takes 92
pitch but - nothing special here but I'm
definitely not not worse I would say I
mean probably maybe very slightly worse
but but not any more
92 I couldn't go King up - then receive
the really takes takes I'll try why not
why not it is a bond cloud I might as
well bring my king back towards the Sun
where it belongs as the theory of this
opening shows maybe six maybe you look
up see 195 any cake
so since 93 I could take I can also play
rotate v6 here which is really kind of
weird I think I'll do it actually I
don't know if it's the best move but
it's interesting so now he's probably
just playing I see fives I mean I think
you play nice you forward here but is
actually surprisingly tricky now and now
I mean now I have absolutely no problems
here at all so those are asking I don't
see I didn't actually set up a donate
donate yet I'll figure that out that's
my first stream so I'm not that familiar
with certain options but but I'll set it
up for you guys now and okay so h6 and I
don't really want to take this grab
that's free pawn on d6 but I think he's
kind of forcing me to so I might as well
just take it I didn't want to I kind of
wanted him to take on e5 he's going to
give me this extra pawn and force me to
take then I will
jealousy's a night before who wants to
go a 93 or something I can Keith 93 King
be one night up I have to draw
I mean drawing it's not allowed this is
a bond cloud on cloud games going on in
draws okay 93 95 this Aoife is not
probably the best move because now he
helps me make my structure whole again
okay it's probably work h2 I don't know
maybe not it's not not so obvious but
I'm not sure what he'll do here so let's
just I guess what was wait and see okay
it's Rick h2 and um let's see what was
that okay uh what was that sorry
check me in here one moves maybe you
have anything worked up - Kim Ji Won
or not okay I don't know what happened
there there's some kind of weird live I
guess that's just me that was really
kind of weird I don't know what happened
there
I was really weird
okay um all right I'll play someone else
now
I was really weird that was just some
kind of weird liar just snuck up on me
out of nowhere really weird so I got
shocked nature's brains still going bit
all right okay
you
all right let's see okay so I will play
who is tanki just told me to play them I
don't their challenge
so the challenges on the scissors who's
going to challenge
okaythat's there we go okay so not next
game against uh okay CK 1886
46 hopeful a king's indian the scam
against its London 93 Oak is they want
to play eat horses actually turn into a
pair of modern type of opening play a
six Bush base six probably takes maybe
not the puns would punch what they're
all my opponents looking for um we'll
see I'll see the castles b5 pretty
standard wanna play d4 under my teeth or
pontil in the night blue second play
night Casey for probably up three navy
e5e5e5 kind of would expect some kind of
a fine maybe sure enough I know
absolutely nothing as we see plays
Bishop d3
let's see three but each I don't want to
move my age on but I think I'll do it I
just don't I don't want I don't want
have to deal with fish page six here
even though it's not really that big of
an issue I don't feel like dealing with
it at this moment in time so lax
obviously 595 East could be strong
probably not even XIV success lies but
definitely not ideal so I'm going to
start playing some hyper modern stuff
movin ITT southern play for c5 or 96
something along these lines something
like this I think so it's 82 now I'll go
c5 you take all this cake back with the
pawn try and play for c4 trapping this
Bishop on d3 maybe not I'm not really
sure but we'll see
so takes takes maybe 95 is a possible
move but in general I'm turning c4 so
they're question there's some dangers
here for for sure so so let's let's see
what's going to do here wait for move me
maybe I'll just move the knight to g3
maybe not a little bit hard to deal with
this c4 threat here okay so he does play
Knight e3 as expected often c4 why not
force the bishop back now I complete b4
here I didn't want to play more
traditional just cleaning 5 or to create
some threats against its Queen side all
over here it's a little bit not really
clear what he's trying to do maybe he'll
go king b1
maybe I'll go B 495 c3 for example or
King b1 maybe just like I don't know
maybe e5 maybe e6 if it prints there to
be 8 but he's not turning me I am
covered all this take my queen on a5 is
covering da so he doesn't have a maid
here
I actually think taking on b8 was
probably rather serious mistake quite
right
I'd say
in 95 I really don't want to have to
exchange Queens but Queen d8 allows
Knight f6 Queen e2 allows 97
I could try c3 if I really want to you
know why not let's look up some fun
there's no reason not to you take I'm
just going to castle and I'm just going
to play as though as though nothing
happened um I assume he'll play Knight
c3 but maybe not
who be c3 Wow Lal Singh okay um hey
probably Queen d5 I would expect an I'm
just going to castle I'm not too afraid
of anything here in fact he actually has
to take with the Queen and I'm just
going to castle not too not too worried
welcome you Queen a one Queen Queen III
Chuck you probably should take the roof
I don't see a mate right away but it's
obviously very hard to do that and now
I'm just going to they work c8
understand i crush them on the C file of
my plan at least the 97 he could have
taken my knight then I was into work c3
or CA just doubled roof on C file I just
resigned okay okay finally I played this
guy but I I thought I'd accepted this
guy's challenge like hour ago or
something but let's Lucy so alright a
dutch a dutch dutch and norwegian
playing a dutch i feel like there should
be a joke in there somewhere but I can't
think of it right off of course magnatum
solvers played the Dutch a few times so
these six castles so some kind of a
Leningrad when grad Doug share play 93
maybe 9066 Queenie ate many different
moves c96 of d5 probably 95 I myself
until a 95 is black a few times one
thing about this 95 line
sleeves to some very strange con
structures where both sides of weird
kind of clamps on on on white has some
pawns on the Queen side black is going a
weird King slide on majority to so
steadily to some rather strange on
structures maybe II for maybe a Queenie
8 e 6 e 6 is a move but I feel like e
switch is slightly wrong on Queen b3 I
mean I I know Lisa is definitely a
playable move trying to create the right
structure but
let's see okay Queenie seven I'll just
play Bishop g5 play play simple tracks
keep it simple
probably you should play e4 here close
down its really strong diagonal from a
bishop and everything
hi Brooke d8 all this play work d1 I'm
just going to keep delaying until the
absolute last possible moment what I
have to do here
I just to keep it complex okay so now he
did play e4 now or that was not quite
right I just going to pawn on c5 attack
but it's not the end of the world
actually
you have three bish plus three
yeah so Queen c5 can't King h1 maybe
it's not actually clear that it's so bad
so you can actually see it you need
shapes hopefully Queen c4 if you take so
play Knight takes d5 you plays the e5
maybe E or maybe something else
Fivey for ellipses so FP 494
um
the h6 all just take and said don't pay
attention to the chat clearly I'm paying
too much attention for the check I'm
getting too long time and most of the
games on but it is fun to look every so
often
okay it's official there hopefully be
four um see what you want to do here a
little bit tricky for blocks players
position
okay so F for reason will move I don't
really want to take on half for I also
just played d6 maybe or I can just
completely ignore and go like g4
I mean g4 looks dubious but I'll do it
anyway just because just to worry about
when i th fiber page for h5 your
speech or Queen Jeep is and kind of I'm
going to attack on the Kings side not
that it's realistic in a sense but it
could occur of course it's clearly
listening to me so I should not be
telling the people who are watching on
the on the channel what what to do so he
heard me but I did put my work on d2 so
that I could meet this Queen v5 with
Rory too and Soph any kind of threats
because now I can't go age five and now
it's bish 1h 4s stuck as well so now I
can continue with the free hand over
here on the on the Queen side which I
will of course do most likely he'll take
maybe he'll go back to seeing maybe not
but this is going to get pretty ugly now
because now I now now P star on the
wrong setting board everything is kind
of off sides and hours before there's
some harmony
it goes back Queen e7 and then I'll just
play with t1 maybe eight six maybe not
I'm not sure but obviously d6 forcing to
take I'll take with a knight I want I
want I want to use this pasty pond or d8
um a c7 or 366 pleased to see a queen I
don't see it or I'll work these if I
don't
clean my pond now that I think about it
sources who who's up next arm
all right so next game
xampp so e for la e 6c they be six I'll
play something weird I'll play something
really weird I'll play one of these
what's this opening called not not the
front replace the nimzowitsch or
something now the throne one remember
all right anyway I played quite a few
times on on chess before so I'll play it
again we'll see works on I have three
Bishop c4 there should be three or four
Knight f6
maybe maybe e5 maybe not maybe Queen e2
I don't actually know who I'm playing
yes I don't know if this one of the
up-and-coming us girls slave in the US
Championship or not I can't actually
tell but anyway maybe five probably
castles
I'll play an endgame here as we know as
the same as the good old saying goes
kids don't know how to play on game so
just make sure to exchange queens and
getting to an end gaming of these them
today they only know tactics of course
nothing else and of course those people
a charm i me does the Owens defense
obviously I can't yeah yeah think
straight
sorry about that being so ignorant so
clean out three Queen f3 g f3 so I
should not not ideal for white here
because Delta two sets of double pawns
you still two bishops with two sets of
double pawn a little bit a little bit
nasty not not quite ideal now here I
could have just taken and got 9594 but I
don't really feel like it I figure it's
there I could I can kind of wait I don't
have to take the bishop right away if at
all if I don't want to take I'll just
move the rook can put my knight on c4
anyway so there's about four point nine
a 5 maybe d5 here I think on d5 I can
the night or even just simpler tables on
maybe there should be three is a move
here would make some sense on what's
still probably okay but nothing nothing
to write home about
so sure enough d5 is played out I'll
take probably Bishop e5 I'll just take
eight rook d5 King c6 probably something
like work do you want or a piece of nm
or are going to take for p5 King c8 even
actually King CA makes more sense just
so it on work d1 I can say rope d8
repeat and go straight for a career for
an endgame so let's see 44
96 so let's just erupted III sorry about
that
um I'll play Brooke Turkey 87 rookie 7
probably working 797 rupees 5 now I can
play work d8 and forsakes change a long
time undone pawns here I should be doing
quite ball if I under bubble pawns White
is probably okay so basically I just
want to force exchanges but without the
works on d3 I take that I undone doubled
pawns there and it's uh and so basically
I want white takes exchanges piece I
want white on double everything I don't
know what's going to do that or not but
we'll see
and actually here whites and a half this
is the point plays rook c1 that I will
take take and take upon in a - so maybe
work the eight nice 298 something like
this maybe not but I'm going to get this
to the version that I wanted all this to
on all exchange and all exchange and
there's a Marisa T of the doubled pawns
are not a good thing
Oh pawns are bad thing especially when
you have two sets of them if you only
have one set it's probably okay but two
sets of double pawns with a night
against Bishop is really quite miserable
because also the other problem here is
the black or not black white set white
can't attack my pawns really well
anytime the efficient have tonight if I
can put my pawns on the opposite color
of the bishop that's going to be really
unpleasant and the bishop can attack any
pawns ways it's two sets of double pawns
so it's pretty ugly okay so a for ultra
Ronan check when I bring my King in now
to see for hopefully be 5 right
exchanged some ponds and now I actually
have another now there's another problem
type that I also going to outside pass
on here too so this is not going to be
good
let's play up five to make sure there no
entry squares for the king and now as a
pawn just going to straight down the
board this is who's up next
okay let's see some want the King's
gambit next on I'm going to want the
Kings gambit who this guy looks like a
real player 23 2309 okay you're a
serious guy
okay fine let's see it
okay they played
94 to force my King back it's okay I
mean I probably probably would not
actually play like this those blacks I'm
gonna get the sector company see it
through the only problem is you could
move my king I'm not some problems here
that's the only issue that I foresee he
could play Bishop you four maybe he's
trying to be funny I'm going to flip
there should be 5 right back at him so
when you take all this take a special
and now I've somehow again accomplished
something that I should not have
anything or maybe after c3 you can play
Queen e6 or something but this still is
already looking better than I should
that's for sure so maybe this opening is
legit and ok if he's going to play like
this then I completely equalized simply
equalizes black out out of the Oakland
or with white out of the open good thing
ok so we're going to play some kind of
we're done game here maybe I were SDA if
you want so e5 or east of cards gonna
finish as development I'm not not really
sure on I mean once put is keen on see a
tall so let's do now I can play e5 here
I don't play e5 he's probably gonna play
d5 back so I kind of have to so let's
so 95 maybe 95 or night he5 yeah let's
let's go for our basic I want to force
in Keaney 8 and I'll play e6 I was going
to have to take and now I'm going to get
an extra pawn or 5695 wow this just
turned out beautifully oh this is just
beautiful this as much as you can ask
for
I'm so b6 I can not go 94 I really
wanted to but that makes me a little bit
unhappy but I'll just go back to b3 on
some people are actually about the watch
is uh what one of the watch that I'm
wearing is as a Fitbit on my right right
hand I tend to wear that most of the
time not always but most of the time um
now my other hand I am actually wearing
a Rolex but it's a Rolex I got as a gift
so no white coin I did well I'm like
coins like coin did not pay for the
watch sighs maybe 97 maybe discrete
seven hotels is something he reports I
realize the problem here is also that
black has also also moved as king so he
thinks he's going to castle which is all
nice and fine but he cannot so like I
think is good at eat bish b7 you're just
thinking I'm just going to cap on this
better but AHA you better slow down you
can't quite castle Pietro's f1 that this
is turned out really nice right now this
is just this is a dream all I have to do
is basically figure out how to activate
this bishop and then they'll be home for
you pretty much it plays a five almost
play for soft stop it from doing
anything over here
tonight of six I could take tonight I'll
just plain I see two for now I don't
really see any reason not to taking in
Bishop III was also pretty strong but
I'd rather keep sudden I really like
this Knight outpost on you for thank you
for on i-24 was that was kind of mean he
wasn't supposed to do that
I just three woke up five I got hollows
play Knight c4 not crazy about the way
that I'm happened I should I should have
just taken the night on have sex that
but I provide about this move so pledged
his life such as life's over cage one
probably night up three maybe I can go
King you two and Bishop III I don't I
don't know it's fast but I'll I'll try
it work out five and this to speed3
because you plays 94 I just take taking
up two but after work f5 he's
threatening to put a knight on d4 I need
to put a bishop on - III to prevent that
so he doesn't have any 94 of nonsense
but at the same time always PSR again
like kind of not hard not harmonize at
all this night in this rook aren't quite
right though it's 94 tack and now only
goes in H u5b hangs of 406
let's see what he's going to do fighting
on but there's not really much left to
fight fight on for I'll just take them
on take another pond put a roof on each
one try to meet them on the eighth
you can go kini 8 8 s 6 pretty ugly
okay so ever link ever long time let's
see those who are wondering I will I
will play a couple of good guys again
before all said and done so far are
pretty normal I'm going to go you for
rate break the structure it's going to
turn some kind of caro-kann type of
structure where's the akka when you need
him
oh and for those someone said something
about my shirt um yeah so for those who
accurate looking and says a wings for
life charity run not charity well yeah
it was a charity run on in May as this
year happens every year help people
whose spinal cord injuries so for those
who are wondering what I'm wearing it's
a t-shirt from Attabad
v6 41 this would be seven
I could please c4 c4 c3 put upon
somewhere I'm just going to put a bish
1g5 play play traditional castles 95
done just don't bother with the Queen
side as long as I can that is basically
I just want to feel like Queenie to work
d1 or 95 and queen up 3 maybe just
ignore anything over here like no need
to commit to c4 c3 or any of that as I
was saying I'm just going to completely
ignore everything just play freaking
slide 95 might have been a little bit
better than Queenie 2 because now after
95 is made of four tricks but shouldn't
shouldn't matter that much
fish broth six again I'm just going to
ignore it just play rook t1 but now I am
going to go c4 with the tomahawk
considered a knight on d5 in it in a
second it's probably he will cast one
out I would assume or not he's going to
play queen b7 which is probably pretty
pretty bad actually so after 95 okay so
he takes I'll take with the pawn of
course just to open up open up this
defiled is a knight and a queen on the D
file he's still probably kind of okay
because he's right on the edge between
being okay and being in a lot of trouble
that's what I asked me to chat
Mayweather or McGregor I don't actually
think that's much of a quieter I think
it's pretty obvious isn't it when the
fight one of them is a box are one of
them is not a boxer um so we'll see but
I think it's pretty clear to me who's
gonna win the fight you guys can keep
asking questions in the chat as well I
will actually see them periodically from
time to time
rookie six may be 98 here or c5 one of
the tumulus probably has to be played
let's see five um I could take on b7 I
think I actually will just because when
he takes I always am going to have a
check in hand once he takes hopefully
worth d1
you
so now someone else asks me like if I
play play video as an engineer O's and
magic sorry um I assume by magic they're
referring to the card game which I have
not played in probably like 15 years at
least so no I do not play money on many
games for that matter each horse
probably bad no I just provided to you
five here for some reason that's stupid
but I'll find a way to put some pressure
on so I'll go between d3 make them
decide is going to go King c8 if you're
going to go move as work off the default
I think King C is almost forced move
here or you can play Knight d5 which one
I understand
I'll just take upon I put a pretty good
fight for a while at just 95 you should
have gone King seed instead of 95 and it
probably would have been fine but but
now it's kind of in the water fudge
problem you take on d6 e d6 but it is
all pretty pretty bad pretty bad at
least
I'm going to someone else take a free
rook
another question actually I just know
this is a question that everyone asks me
for some reason knows these believe me
and I'm just using a standard logitech
cordless mouse nothing special on
everyone seems to think that I have some
kind of special mouse which I do not so
that's that's how it's always been I've
never used specials but I've never had
any special Mouse special mice so um so
that's the short short and simple answer
okay so oh did I accidentally accept
this guy again I thought I accepted
someone else okay hopefully something
weird but this this game all just
something really weird like me oh I'll
play nine eight six five six because he
is putting a night off seven is about
score in the world
there should be three hopefully five
it's going to turn to some kind of Kings
Indian type of position d5 d6
maybe he'll play c5 maybe I'll play
Knight f3 I'm not actually sure what his
order is going to be I'll play us five
right away probably up three maybe he'll
take and play off four or something or
maybe he'll just play up for right away
it seems really wrong but mostly finally
chief I've left four and plop something
on e5 was my plan
oh I didn't expect Lee played there
should be four that was stupid that was
really stupid I thought I was going to
play Bishop up to now this is going to
be tricky could be kind of unpleasant
actually so g4 clean off 493 maybe I am
going to do it just to avoid any
nonsense but I have quite amazed it's
rather messy so it's probably not that
bad objectively
now 493 takes takes probably night g2 I
would assume maybe multiple different
eyes probably Queen Queen f6 is always
there cleaning six Queen off six you
could always go back to d2 I'll just put
post-op earn exchange of Queens
especially with the pawn structure with
these positive e4 d 5 c4 um I can't
exchange the Queen time so probably okay
or the fight has the pawn on d4 it would
be much force with the pawn on d5 is
it's probably reasonably okay so
probably okay so Rick outflowing queen
you've suffered probably efficiency to I
would assume all the sleeve is would be
seven I wanted to play a five nineteen
ninety five ninety four doesn't feel
quite right to now play a five I'm going
to be castling long in a second to a
trial its castle
maybe h6 doesn't really do much though
the oven okay so you please 93 what
should I play here all this flavor p8
making go Knight a5 here of course it's
always an option I'm just going to take
it he takes the pawn I'll go clean up
six the cases the rook I'm not sure what
I'm going to do I'll probably just sleep
at the Aten try to exchange another set
of rooks and now if he takes he takes
this way I think I can play gypsy 3 I
don't really want to those so I think on
this one is likely h4
maybe III maybe not I'm not actually
sure I'll see you look up seven which
seems wrong
okay the BC 3 now how do i do something
I guess I'll just throw on track MV to
Queen G 2
page seven then I might have rookies for
a Jay King d7 ug5 it's all throwing a
chuckle to : first probably King b3 I
would expect fortune I don't think
there's a whole lot I can do here I
think I'll try the Alltel trial try I'll
try the straws they're just terrible no
wants to make any drawers and it can be
seven probably age 17 - oh dude I saw
HEA take c4 oh maybe I did that maybe
that was not cracked
it's a request seven which is definitely
a blunder - not since they were key for
oh wait a second so I'm pleased 3d cakes
like check doesn't work if I move my
queen I don't know what I'm doing here
but I'm doing something
so now I really need to just start
moving really fast here see how fast I
can move personally there again there's
there's quite a bit of lag coming in I'm
annoying
that was a blender bottom a check now
to just be a draw
there is an insane amount of lag
ah no there's too much lag
well much lag oh well
and now too much lag do anything about
that proportionately a bit ridiculous
for whatever of course - he would have
lost a key and there was obliged but
whatever what I wrote soon
- so kind of 3c5 castle id3
ha
probably 95 like I saw this in a book
like a hundred years ago maybe there's a
way scan book that I saw it in honestly
I think it's called we'd continue to
chess or something like that I feel like
that cause exact line did you have six
fish page six
key aides I don't remember how the
flying goes I'll play commute one maybe
Queen d7 okay so they just take on White
House goes the screech five calculate up
or maybe maybe I would be weird
the page five out for Bishop d1 works
you one can 88 all okay this doesn't
quite work should be a force meetin for
this computer takes a worksheet a
exclaims you one Bishop you for takes
maybe seven
King King a favor to a queen g1 me and a
couple
and shut me alright let's see so
cept this guy got Sauron I played this
guy once before I'm willing to play you
guys let's see okay one second
ever a TGIF
system I think that is that the British
flaggers as Georgia it's Georgia okay
it's about to say his playing in honor
of his country but I'm not
yeah it's Georgia it's not not London or
Tbilisi I should say c3 um could take
all 8585 solid move just take half the
tape with the e pawn here takes a seat
on there's Bishop b4 track probably he
takes d4 point 94 why not this is
Detroit I can probably just plain I take
C 3 maybe maybe not not not sure but
maybe maybe so let's see so a 2 6 Oh
take look upon c5 try and break up the
structure creates and threats right away
if you think I'll take with the bishop
maybe he plays out three knight f6 but
it's sold a little bit on Pleasant
Bishop III all this tape 54 Bishop c5
[Music]
cd4 I'm not sure so probably takes
Bishop up to King d1 or Fe da
she's 525 probably again he well he has
to compete sorry here I guess this it's
not so bad actually I thought I thought
maybe there's a little bit worse than
this but still again capsule d5 probably
9 to 24 over p1e4 pretty much a key for
no matter which which movie me
for castles
there's bar 5 I'll just play a 5 fix the
Pont aeri the backward Ponzi 3 backward
pond and be for any kinetically b4 c4 so
we exchange is all to take back with my
ass Brooke
is something else that you can do here
I'm not really sure
[Music]
okay Rick see one cake I don't really
want I can play with v8 don't really
want to but I'll just take I'll take any
now five and I'll point 94
when I take three g6 clamp three nights
III Queen takes d5 I'll play g6 anyway
let's bring out three on 82 queen bee
one movie not not so simple
let's plan quite well I'll play up five
I'll go all and just tack them might be
five maybe off or maybe or 58
well display Rocky
three I'm not going to exchange
obviously want to play out for f3 or g5g
for a four out of three I'm quite a King
side attack though for sure it's you
just played f3 and we play up for overly
want to so I'll play 95 now our next
move is going to be up for prefer or not
if you play turkey 1 we apes we want to
do play roughly 1 play B 4 B 4 is a move
but the danger behind B 4 so now he's
giving me how I lecture passed on to the
center I've got to connected or maybe
not you can actually take on d4 I guess
no I did I do that
ah such a bad room well I'm going to fly
and listen on how I wanted to win only
one Queen B to not Queen a to well that
was strange but
and that was not ideal
but well selves there's always the flag
I play members of this one I'll play
I'll play a male players I mean tirage
who wants to if you take on d5 I'll take
with a knight probably for build the
center Ponzi for d4 c3 I think it also
just take on d5 III is a little bit
passive I'll play c5
I love the 57 oh it takes Queen d7
all right let's see
three alpha 96 Castle Hill fellas take
play Bishop e7 a Christmas oven could be
reasonable three couple moves all all
this castle I'll let him take a take
upon temporarily if he wants to okay he
doesn't harm - yeah maybe queen bee
three nine eight five you take on c5
Queen c7 probably Oh 23 just under two
piece that's P four so if he takes I
take the bishops and move the am
protected there's money three bases
okay Rafi 395 is dropping dropping
another exchange unfortunately we can go
somewhere and I'll just take the take
the rook Thanks
many moves like a player I'll just look
at their spawn off a play g6 bitter
abusive and make sure no need to learn
adjust the rest will be pretty
straightforward
and what's another piece for the canteen
son I take his Queens we just dropped
and drop is nice so unfortunately it's
going to be over soon I think I'm going
to finish probably the next couple games
probably play some legitimate players
I'll try and play with an increment
though just like nothing nothing insane
happens I think someone's much of that
in the chat so I think that's probably
what I'm going to do I'll probably feel
like a cover someone okay I'll play I'll
play Yakov and I think I'll challenge
you I'll cop to like three two or
something three minutes
I think I'll challenge in two three two
he wants a twitch maybe he doesn't maybe
he doesn't so let's see challenge Igor
nope no game yet wait a few more minutes
see if anyone a strong wants to play it
off and I'll get back to playing with
you guys again
so Jakob does not want a player he does
he's online but
all right so instead I'll play too weak
too slow man
seriously I thought the other name was
funny but the pictures uh something else
ha ha ha
guys this one's a humor he's seven all
right then I'm not going to take it easy
I'm going to go straight for straight
for the kill
all right fish before I'm not going to
let him to row with his uh his original
version of the bond cloud great concept
as long as your opponent doesn't try to
kill you right out of the opening oh I
didn't realize this was the original guy
who suggested I played it hahaha okay I
haven't something after this game
neither was going to want to play it
though with white or black
so far is that doing okay I mean I'm not
I'm not sure how long tweet whistle is
going to survive this opening but so far
he's he's trying he has a few issues
here unfortunately but he's trying
has to try and develop again ofE 595 I
guess we're not eat five I guess I'll
just take I'm going to throw in a check
this is not going to be very pretty I
don't think and select it's going to be
pretty ugly and second maybe King d8
maybe I guess King da try to hold on um
yes I don't know d6 is right or not
it looks d6 or Bishop c6 maybe
okay I won't snap so d6 cd6 Queen D 60 X
907 for sure is winning a piece do it
better than that takes 95 26 now I don't
have better than that so you guys I have
to go for this isn't really what I
wanted to go for but all this will make
it work kind of it's not really the
intention so cd6 castles ft 5 maybe is a
more aggressive approach I think it's
probably the right approach attacked
yeah I saw this castle nobody plays epi
5 I'll play Knight d5 overloading is
Queen because it's protecting this
Bishop which on yeah so you have to take
now so there was Bishop Hanks's queenie
a bishop take the 8 so you have to
exchange
so it takes takes probably work c8 work
up southern maybe um that looks pretty
good or work c8 Bishop h4 also is
interesting but push page for Knight f6
so we're cast 7 Knight f6 57 95 d7 King
the a46 he needs 7 or 55 and I'm
swinging just an extra piece ok so takes
Queen 6 I think
actually just grab this punks when he
takes over 51 check
Thank You 757 and it's going to be neat
pretty soon maybe King cat2 rides for
like an extra three moves he's going to
survive for like an extra three moves
takes fact King da Queen d7 ishaq
minutes we probably put in be a fish
grades so he gets the one last check in
but now I can even just pre move between
b7 and Chuck
okay except this guy before or not I'm
not sure if I did but I see a very
familiar flag that looks like the flag
of Sri Lanka pretty unmistakable flaw
right you guys I think I'll play this
game and then I'll play one more after
this so I'll see who the lucky uh what
the finalists are final two the lucky
lucky looking person is
takes off for there should be two simple
develop make it make it normal make it
look good Aoife interesting
welcome to I was expecting something
actually CalSTRS was a bad move now he's
Queen h4 it was actually really poor on
Queen h4 g3 can just a convenient for H
series Queen genes rework up three maybe
match for h3 push page three maybe maybe
we'll see
all pledged through anyways I'm Bishop
h3 I think I'll just play cleaning one
try to exchange or something right
please clear listening to the CXC play
Queen to you through but now after work
h3 Queen and shoot King off - I think
I'm kind of surviving because I need
have anything
nothing's hanging I could just exchange
Queens next move like you can try I
don't know what he can try you're
actually which would be 6 th 1/2 5 th
one Bishop to e3 is a serious idea okay
so f5 maybe I should play Bishop to c5
or maybe I just like Queen h1 anyway
come on Bishop t3 I can just take up
before a block of their stuff 3
I guess in chat just a since I watched
Game of Thrones the answer is yes I do
watch Game of Thrones watched washer
pretty religiously I never actually read
the books but I have a big fan of the TV
series for those who are interested
looking forward to season seven I think
it should be coming out sometime soon
that feel like but I'm not sure the
exactly
you're perceived free I'll take probably
taking them as we're taking the change
in the bishop for the night is not the
right idea here because I don't be it's
a little bit bad and you know blacks an
extra pods much easier for white to
solidify everything like c4 c5 and the
two bishops are quite good as well it's
the other thing this is probably wasn't
wasn't the ideal way probably now he
almost happily be 695 and hope that he
can salvages even though blacks up upon
white white has all the trumps in the
position okay rook e8 is a move on he is
I guess threatening to play III take 93
soldiers block and now I also broke up
one check its Knight b6 that's a good
move hopefully g4 just make sure he
doesn't unfished off fiber move this
Knight to f5 somehow because everything
here on the Queen side is very solid
can't attack my pawns which are
protected might as well take some space
on the King side in the meantime 7l
Tobruk up one now now I want to go work
up seven if you mr. King you want candy
since I've cease I do I'm anything
better now not really it'll take I'll
take a knight or if you want to me seven
Wow okay that was weird
I'll play work up six c5 I'll just take
he sure on double as pawns or be c6
Bishop c4 I'm going to go work up seven
track and a mover - I think I'll retreat
obtuse p5 is better not not quite right
I could be five maybe work up seven
anyway da all this take
yeah okay well all right you guys I
think I think I'm going to stop for now
so quite a bit of fun I've tried to
answer most your question the chat I
don't think I got to mode some obviously
firstling hours so I simply didn't have
out the window open so anyway you guys I
hope you enjoyed it so this is my first
first string here on Twitch and I'm
Charlie back to do more in the future so
until next time you guys to take care of
keep it real and I'll be back soon so
have a good day everyone okay bye